[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay we'll take the shortcut
welcome to occupy the Castro we want to
thank the organist Warren Lubitsch
and the amazing team here at the Castro
theater I'm Stuart bran from the long
now foundation I'm gonna put in a brief
pitch for membership how many members of
the long now foundation are here who
you're probably gonna show your cards
and call your numbers we're almost to
4,000 members and like we're 3680 you
can do the math we'd love to get the
4,000 by the end of the year when that
happens the membership will be
supporting one-third of the whole
general fund of the long now foundation
with all of its activities and that
makes you members the largest donor so
thank you now and in advance members
besides getting guaranteed seats and
quote free tickets to these events
seminars about long-term thinking also
get early access to some things there's
gonna be a major announcement of an hour
10,000 year clock which you may know is
now under construction in the West Texas
that will come to the members first and
we're contemplating a whole new project
which is a deep dark secret for now
members will be the first to know about
it because we need your help while it's
still tentative thinking it through
so membership involves engagement at an
intellectual level
Rick Bellinger is joined tonight by
panelists who've we got Edie Holmes and
woody Labonte who he will introduce Rick
Bellinger show us what film history
looks like thanks Stuart my god the
Castro I mean what happens is it back to
counter pulse after this maybe it should
be um thank you all for coming how many
of you are for this is your first loss
landscape show
whole bunch okay welcome welcome number
six very difficult to believe some of
you some of you who I hope would be here
or not here and I hope you'll tell your
friends then we're gonna have a repeat
screening on January 24th that Internet
Archive let's see a couple things I
wanted to say I owe thanks to many many
people for helping to make this come
together it's more names and I could
ever read right now but the credits at
the end of the film will show you a long
list of people who've donated home
movies and family films shared them with
me led me to new sources as I always say
I would be delighted to hear from any of
you who have material or who know of any
and for those of you who've donated form
but not yet seen it please forgive me
for being slow you've shared abundance
and it takes a while to sift through
abundance Stuart mentioned our panelists
we have at Holmes who is a longtime San
Francisco transgressor his career has
encompassed membership in the San
Francisco mime troupe he's also Bishop
Joey on sait stupids day of the First
Church of the last laugh and will
contribute years of San Francisco
experience and maybe a note of a note of
unserious Ness to this
woody Labonte aided by David Gallagher
of the Western neighborhoods project
which is an amazing local history
institution outside lands org for you
for you who have your smartphones on by
the way you can leave them on tonight is
the first high-def lost landscapes
screening so forgive me mic glitches it
combines images from many sources
travelogues industrial films and these
amazing what are called process plates
in Hollywood these background shots that
were made for rear projection in feature
films and a great deal of the footage
tonight comes from home movies so for
years
classical archives focused mostly on
collecting institutional records traces
of history that were left by governments
by corporations by organizations by
churches and so on but you know today
we've tipped into an age where
individuals are creating vast amounts of
data and if it's kept the historical
trails will be thick and dense and in
fact I think personal records which
include home movies have overtaken the
records of organizations institutions
and governments certainly in mass and I
think importance and if you imagine the
archives of the future you know I spend
a bunch of time thinking about the
archives of the future I think people
are gonna be much more interested in
records relating to individuals lives
than otherwise already you know
genealogy and local history are very
popular and we need to think about what
we're gonna save how we're gonna save
how we're gonna make it accessible it's
the key to understanding history memory
in the future of archives I mean it's
sort of personal records entry interest
to public a lot more than others you
know I don't do so much with educational
films anymore I love home movies and
here are some thousand thirteen hundred
of you plus waiting to watch other
people's home movies so that kind of
proves the point and you know personal
records even just home movies they're
essentially infinite so if we can figure
how to save them we've licked a big big
problem and also home movies and and and
the records of individuals lives are
kind of a workaround because so much
history is under copyright it's locked
down it's enclosed very hard to touch
very hard to work with so that although
we might not be able to use a piece of
music in something that we might make
ourselves we could use people dancing we
could use people reacting we could use
the way that it impacted our personal
lives and you know finally records of
ordinary people's lives they cut to the
core about how we think about sharing
and transparency
everybody often lots of journalists talk
about how we're living in very
transparent times but you know we really
aren't because governments and
corporations know much more about us
than we know about them and aside from
those of us that are still active on
Facebook we don't really like strangers
knowing what we're doing so we kind of
have to figure this out of we may have
to wait for a society that's built on
greater trust before we start sharing
these things but so as I always say I
hope this event is as much about San
Francisco's future as it is about the
fascinating past and the new issue of
the new California Northern Magazine of
any of you seen this it's a really worth
looking at it's on imagining utopia and
in it my co librarian Megan says people
who jump nimbly between historical
consciousness and future-oriented
thinking have particularly attitude to
build flourishing utopian spaces which I
think sounds like a pretty good
description of us in this room tonight
people who jump nimbly between
historical consciousness the future
oriented thinking let's not I'm gonna
follow Stuart with his occupy the Castro
let's not simply accept the adulterated
versions of utopia that you can buy with
a credit card I've bonded with my
smartphone
- but utopia is not a product this is
one of these moments in history where
large numbers of us are thinking about
the kind of
world that we'd like to spend our lives
in so after the show let's go out and
make it happen
so finally you are the soundtrack most
of these films are silent and even if
they weren't you have permission and I'm
really asking you speak up if you've
been here before you know what this is
all about if you know what something is
yell it out if you don't ask a question
if you dispute what somebody else has to
say make some noise and we'll have a
great time thank you so much
[Applause]
this is our traditional opening this was
shot by mr. John summers in August 1941
as he flew into SFO
no he was a fair paying passenger yes it
is but it's bigger that's the kind of
insight we get at these events I spend a
year thinking those things up yes
friendly skies take off your shoes take
off your shoes
this is about 1947 and it's an outtake
from an unknown feature film maybe
somebody can identify it the studio is
Columbia Pictures this is a very big
room so you're going to have to raise
your voices very good free popcorn
[Music]
that didn't carry over to Bart eating on
burning
[Music]
and we're coming off the baybridge the
Fremont Street off-ramp in the late 40s
Rincon Hill
primer the primer coat Lincoln Hill is a
fashionable part of San Francisco in the
1850s and they kept cutting away and
cutting away at and then finding the Bay
Bridge pretty much obliterated it yeah
so this is the material that was shot to
be the background in a movie scene
somebody might be sitting in a cab and
you would see this projected in the
background okay so you've all seen
Market Street 1906 just before the
earthquake right many times over you've
all had it emailed so this is a similar
trip backwards but it's Market Street in
the late 30s and shortly we'll go to
wartime Market Street and I just the
detail on this material is so rich
compared to the Market Street of today I
wanted you all to be able to see this
actually this is this is 1943 ish
Packard on the right we're getting a an
identification of the car on the right
and that's the Ferry Building in the
background there's your induction
station on the left there
yes fundraising during the war
I saw Patrick and company which I've
bought things at yeah you can buy a like
file folder for $35 there nevermind I'm
exaggerating lots of parking on Market
Street though you can park there well
this was during the war when pleasure
driving was banned and the nationwide
speed limit was 35 and you needed you'll
see ration stickers and the front
windows windshields of cars so not all
these cars are necessarily supposed to
be out there see those little square
stickers there's the bear but mechanic
statue just passing over there left to
the left on battery statue the bear but
mechanics if you see haven't seen that
see that great sign on it spinning over
there and these are the white front cars
of the Market Street Railway that was
like a hypno wheel like support the war
effort and this is all filled dirt San
Francisco to us everything from battery
down to the eastern edge is fill dirt
this is yeah that's the one well the the
J car that's Muni so the letters are but
the one this is the one California you
know you get on the bus today but it
used to be a streetcar
that's a cowcatcher
catch all the cows the rack is to scoop
up people that fell down in front of it
seriously it was it was supposed to be a
safety thing but apparently it didn't
really work right so it just diced him
into julienne fries so somebody asked
where this film comes from it was a a it
was from a studio stock footage library
and they junked it its nitrate and this
is a high def transfer from the original
35 millimeter negative which is why
there's so much great detail so it's
California School of Beauty culture this
block is removed for the Powell Street
Plaza holiday Plaza oh there's the
telling news that's the one Jacqueline
that was the one used to show only
newsreels is that right 24 hours a day
newsreels newsreels and also by the way
some industrial films
the Humboldt Bank building up on the
left on 4th 4th and mark yeah it's near
4th 5th and 6th it's just 4th they think
I could be wrong yeah we're at 6 we're
talking about the Humboldt Bank building
so this is burlesque right
I don't think public transportation was
much faster back then than it is today
it seems pretty slow health food store
painless Parker
okay it's post-war and we're at market
and about this is Van Ness coming up and
we're coming into town that's more like
it but this neighborhood was exciting
back then
it's the Twitter building
yeah the Fox Theatre on the right there
there goes so these four tracks on
Market Street with all the streetcars
people are getting run over all the time
if you look at the old newspapers it's
like I couldn't I couldn't believe how
often people are getting mangled by a
streetcar
they were tougher back then right Rick
so we're turning down about to turn down
six
the golden Gate's still there it's the
European version Frisco
anybody have problems with it calling
this city Frisco no right okay
sailors and gold miners called it that
so it's okay 33 Buick
[Laughter]
Merry Christmas
[Music]
Kaiser Building
[Music]
[Applause]
I was so worried it was gonna be a
freeway everything I'm sorry that was
that was the best part of the film
[Music]
it's a health club now
[Music]
[Music]
women only benches
[Music]
one-percenter the park used to have all
sorts of animals herds of sheep and that
sort of thing going a part that was from
a 1935 Fox Movietone film donated by
Jack Tillman II thank you jack who's in
the audience tonight is in the audience
this is Market Street at dusk during the
war people are getting ready to party
yeah there's the telling news again
this is market in Castro 1932 snow on
Twin Peaks yeah 32 there are tons of
photos everybody went out and took a
picture tonight will be no exception so
this is the old produce market which is
now the Golden Gateway center we just we
were heading down Washington Street
where are we now Davis that's right this
is the only footage of this place I've
ever seen it was torn down in their
early 60s thieves highway was filmed
on-location
uh-huh the film thieves highway it was
filmed on location here I wonder if
these are outs from outtakes from
thieves highway
it was a blighted part of town they were
going to oh this is the old Hall of
Justice and Portsmouth square it's the
only footage I had so I slowed it down
so this is these are home movies from
the G family you may remember from past
years this is a little excerpt Kathy G's
in the audience tonight and this is the
the mid to late 40s and Kathy what is
this school do you remember gene Parker
yeah
to close
and some just a few feature outtakes
many many films were set in Chinatown
with very you know very little regard
for what the real Chinatown was like but
the footage has great documentary value
there's quite a lot of this so I just
picked a few clips that's a Wimpy yeah
Wimpy was the name of the camera person
I thought maybe it was a Popeye movie or
something the li-po bar jaysene yep
I can see Barbra Streisand in the
passenger seat yes Grant Avenue formerly
DuPont Street DuPont guy
DuPont guy it's not Chinese food
he probably well this is a low-budget
bullet version didn't have a car
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was the trailer and these are the
outtakes
North Beach yeah this is the the non
touristy side of North Beach
this is an upper Kearny right
there's no parking then either and look
at all the garbage
I mean people it was dirty back then too
everybody acts like you know we're the
only ones drop in our Twinkie wrappers
but so they're covering the different
angles right if two people were skiing
in a car so that they could this is the
the beer hall which I like right up
there pool oh okay where we do people
know where we're going
exactly Telegraph Hill before the
streets were all paved this is just
about 1927 I think it had just opened up
a year or two before I think isn't it
yeah with a turntable
[Music]
[Music]
fisherman's rock I think we need some
chase music so did it it did it it did
it the Embarcadero Freeway is under
construction did it we're all of one
mind on that these are outtakes from the
lineup 1957 yeah we will see more from
this but they left an amazing trail of
San Francisco footage I like it when the
actors don't get in the way he's trying
to tell you something bad that's why
Market Street right there
the Ensign cafe it said bloody Thursday
July 5 1934 Stewart Street Auto ffred
building
this is where the bad guy meets his end
in the lineup right yep he drives up
here and of course give it away don't
give it away right all right all right
well you know it's not gonna end good
[Laughter]
[Music]
I come from the land of fog
today
it's good for your complexion well as
woody said everybody photographed the
snowstorm these are two families home
movies of the snowstorm cut down from I
would say 15 minutes
climate change this Nob Hill isn't it
they would lift on I think on California
Lafayette Square thank you
good question
until about 1933 you had to be
comfortable because home movies costs
this is another family the Larsen family
home movies cost about two dollars a
minute which today would be about 25 a
minute more or less and then in 1933
they put out 8-millimeter and in the 30s
you start to see working-class people
shooting home movies and suddenly home
movies become diverse and they encompass
just a wide variety of experience and
activities and they get really really
cool but this is sixteen millimeter this
was a comfortable family do you know
what the location is here Rick I don't I
need help
it kind of looks like the marina
somebody's I think that maybe might be
the marina this was the the Larsen
family was it a school day of a snow day
but here we're somewhere else now that
looks west of Twin Peaks yep we got a
house number here for the benefit of
Western neighborhoods detectives we
think 1408 that's too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
too much mercury
[Music]
[Music]
so Fisherman's Wharf was a wartime
security zone you see the sign
no cameras permitted US Army this is
Jefferson this is an unidentified family
visiting San Francisco in about 1959
eBay yep
Oh so okay here people are congregating
on the site of the panama-pacific
International Exposition or PPI II this
is a footage from Jack Tillman II thanks
so much again and I wonder if anybody
can tell us a little more about what's
going on
I think it's groundbreaking ceremony
isn't it
sure yeah that's the old gas
I don't know how that gas thing works
but that was in the marina for years
that giant gas building by Safeway well
the fair was in 1915 so I think a little
earlier yes oh this must have been a
couple years before well over 13 maybe a
lot of it was fill this is this is where
washerwoman's Lagoon was right in that
area where it used to be marshland
essentially and and when they had the
fair they were like great we'll have a
fair we'll get everybody out here and
then we'll build a whole bunch of houses
on it there's really wonderful pictures
at the San Francisco main library
website from here at this time
this is Crissy Field in the very late
20s very early 30s
crash
oh right so it's got to be early 30s
there's the bridge I'm forgetting my
preparation aha
this footage comes from Phil our know
there's trails that have been named
after mr. Arno and this is these are his
family films and it's the bridge opening
those lights yeah they were those lights
were there from the beginning
and in 87 there were like a half a
million people did the walk on the
bridge anybody anybody be there anybody
raise your hand if you were on the
bridge you almost died that day yeah my
wife was in the middle and the bridge
went like this one yeah this is another
family on the same day
Tai was always required in San Francisco
didn't they say the tolls were gonna pay
for the bridge then it'd be free they
always do this is some random probably
honeymoon footage family from Tennessee
aha Ocean Beach Playland hey there's the
chutes ride it was like a water ride
with no seatbelts and that windmill the
Murphy windmill just got restored if you
go out there you can see it yeah so in
the late 50s now this is when the
Whitney brothers I think owned the Cliff
House and Sutro Baths well we have
Whitney Brothers fans yeah ice skating
then swimming wasn't paying real well
anymore and they were going with a
tropical theme you could go to the beach
inside Sutro Baths where they had sand
and then they had ice skating nearby
which was kind of an odd juxtaposition
there it is not enough people I should
turn their camera over to the baths
what are you looking at yeah that's the
giant camera the camera obscura inside
there
that's just what's on all these process
plates so you could get a little context
here
this is soot rose outtakes from the
lineup those nuns look suspicious
awesome there's your ice skating great
I've never seen that rig that's cool
yeah you had to go PI the little Museum
in there where they had Egyptian mummies
real Egyptian mummies and coin
collections and stuffed Pumas and
anybody walked a coastal trail up from
merry way this is the coastal trail in
1927 and where you see the little bit of
a shipwreck now that square piece of
metal there's the shipwreck mile right
yeah what's this vessel well that could
be there was a few shipwrecks there but
there were sister ships the Lyman
steward and the Frank guess buck and
they were built in the same shipyard and
launched the same year and they crashed
in the same place it's certain typical
stuff like that always happens around
here yeah Louise is back in business
hooray merry way parking lot
oh no seal rock seal Rio yeah hey that's
Papa opps TV that was around four years
that van is this lineup - yeah this is
this is a outs from the chase scene in
the lineup one of the chase scenes yeah
you're gonna end up at the Veterans
Hospital over here
Fort Miley vets hospital is on the right
how did I get this film I'm the the
studio Ava - a friend of mine and a
friend of mine sold it to somebody else
and somebody else junked it and Internet
Archive now owns that and I've
transferred it for us tonight yeah I
think we're gonna go up to the palace of
the Legion of Honor it looks like in the
Lincoln Park this was a cemetery back in
the 1800s and now it's a golf course
same thing filled with bodies filled
with bones some of the same residents
right yeah oh hey down by 3rd Street the
Bayside motel went derelict some years
back hourly rates right what's that hood
ornament who knows that hood ornament
Ford No so from Jack Tillman II this I
believe is is Valencia Street and I
believe it's a parade to see the the
American soldiers off to World War one
which would make this about 1917 maybe
some people who know about the mission
have some other thoughts well there's a
campaign sign Ralph for mayor of there
so I mean roll sorry and Ralph Ralph
Malph you'll see a bunch of kids from
different schools with their their
school banners shortly as well you got
some kind of hip-hop thing going there
so the Valencia car that give have a
sword I think that kid had a sword
oh there's Fairmont school and share it
in over in the ocean view that's shared
in school that banner is still in the
lobby of the Sheridan grammar school I
saw somebody here with a kilt tonight
right so where's this I thought it might
be David Gallagher no pressure
this is this a gas station at the corner
of Monterey and San Jose Avenue near
Joost in 1939 at this intersection is
completely obliterated now by the by the
280 freeway just nothing there but it
used to go
San Jose Avenue used to come down behind
us to the right and up to the left is
Monterey Boulevard near Glen Park yeah
we're kind of looking easterly so that's
Monterey Boulevard so this film as we
see tonight through the courtesy of our
local filmmaker and friend Scott stark
who's collected let's
the wonderful filmmaker and person as
well as collected a lot of San Francisco
material in this dates from about 1939
it's Kodachrome which you know if you
keep it cool and dry the colors will
last hundreds of years 32 Dutch 32 32
Dutch and that's gin there you can see
this gas station on the 1938 aerial
shots that are now on the David Rumsey
collection
all right go rumble seat el Terra Val
somewhere all right you saw this last
year these are the the glider trials
over the Sunset District people used to
build their own gliders and take them
out there launch them from the hilltops
and this is what the west side of San
Francisco looked like we think about
1920 possibly 1919
this footage turned up a basement on
23rd Avenue so and material from the
Pellegrini family this is I believe
Sloat in the great highway 1937 ish and
keep watching closely those of you who
live in the sunset because another one
of these very unusual shots of the
sunset before it was built out sand
dunes anybody placed this okay this is a
film beach from nineteen thirty seven
thirty nine ish and where'd where are we
wearing the sunset somewhere definitely
but watch the periphery watch what's
what's at the borders this is these are
new houses but they're built right on
the dunes
they look like Oliver Rousseau houses
which are over near Sunset Boulevard
just east of Sunset Boulevard around
37th Avenue
it's the 1500 block well that's almost
right block and see the dunes in the
background palm trees to it like that
and the dunes in the background there as
well yeah your house would just end and
then it would be nothing but sand dunes
to the side you try to plant a garden
then it would be buried the next morning
yeah we could find where this is rigged
yeah nature culture interface right
there
Easter time
that's amazing oh hey there's the Breen
gate we're going to go and get Park on
19th Avenue in about 1959 okay so these
are films from John Gorman former
examiner photographer and filmmaker from
his daughter Nancy O'Gorman and these
boys have just snuck into Laurel Hill
Cemetery so this is over near the where
the JCC and the old fireman's fun
building is between California and
Masonic yeah now it's UCSF I'm sorry I'm
still living 20 years ago I've been
looking for footage of the cemeteries
for years and some has finally showed
this is actually a little film with a
narrative there's a plot here zombies I
won't tell okay and richmond district
boosters one of the cemeteries out for
decades because they thought it impeded
progress to their district from downtown
i think by now many of the remains have
been removed right and they're waiting
to perhaps
oh you mean by the time this footage
yeah yeah they supposedly move the
bodies to Colma most of them including
my great-great-grandmother she got on
earth and moved down there from Laurel
Hill Cemetery
no that's the question
looking for the Illuminati that is
correct
yeah Buena Vista if you go to Buena
Vista Park you can you can see it in the
little rain gutters little bits of
headstone you go out to the Marina
District the wave organ out there is
made up of a lot of old gravestones and
monuments
that's jr. Bob Dobbs with the pipe yeah
hey you hipsters get out of there
these cemeteries fell into a lot of
disrepair because they just basically
started running out of money you've
filled up the graveyard and you didn't
get any new subscribers and they didn't
have the perpetual care money coming in
so they would get kind of overgrown and
they were thought to be unsafe unhealthy
I mean kids used to play with bones and
stuff right they would though they would
bring bones home until it was a problem
too many bones can be a problem yes know
a woman named Trina Lopez a filmmaker
made a wonderful wonderful film which I
urge you to order from her called what
the last final final resting second
final rest is that you Trina it's really
a great film about the the movement and
the controversy of the end of the
cemetery's if you go down to 280 Metro
Center between the Home Depot and the
Best Buy is a lot of the bodies from The
Odd Fellows cemetery got dumped there
and there's one little marker it's kind
of broken in the middle
that's Dick Cheney's tomb right you
can't kill them guys so at the same time
mr. Gorman also photographed the
cemeteries and color and Kodachrome so I
put a little bit of this into just I've
never seen how movies of the cemeteries
I don't want that to be my home this was
16 millimeter correct it's just one roll
one short roll
they started the most the cemeteries
were moved in the late 30s early 40s is
I think when the last ones removed but
they had four big cemeteries Calvary
Masonic Laurel Hill and The Odd Fellows
cemetery and they were all centered
around Geary and Masonic 49 there was
still some yeah the call you can still
get an itch at the Columbarium and be
interred and say well here's US Senator
David Broderick's tomb he died in a duel
over near Lake Merced in 1859 and he was
buried in Laurel Hill
the monuments we're like we said we were
broken up and used as sea wall material
and if you paid for it if you owned one
of them or your relative was buried
there you could pay to have him move
down to the cemeteries in coma but most
people didn't or they couldn't be
located so they broke it up and used it
for billions of prop supplies and that's
progress I guess a bunch were dumped as
as coastal reinforcements off of Sloat
yeah out near the beach yeah the library
has a nice picture of these kids playing
on all these tombstones out at the beach
I'm feeling kind of old right now Rick
you know I'm really great does this get
perkier Hey
it's the evidence bow down it's the
evidence it's almost over woody I don't
like this out of that either
nice cuffs so we're still in the
Richmond District this is Geary
Boulevard what I think around nineteen
sixty-three
heading east from right the Coronet
Theatre in the background Collins Avenue
Collins Street
the bridge supporter neighborhood
theaters house hamburgers
this is before the Gary tunnel was put
in a I believe so
I bet Lucky Penny or copper penny still
over there what do you think is copper
penny over there back then oh there's
the pub it's open Bob look at all those
cars over there so yeah this here's the
cars are lined up to get into Trader
Joe's over there I can see them right
somebody described their neighborhood as
Trader Joe's Heights
yeah Kizer on the left I always wondered
what does anybody know what happened to
the murals I used to be in the Sears
they had those sort of Gold Rush murals
on the walls by the way Richard
Brautigan lived in one of those
buildings across from Sears in the
background
trout fishing in America
No okay where are we Western Addition I
know that but there's a laundry which
may be on Ellis Street that's about to
come up so we could be on Ellis the
Henry laundry
looks ripe for redevelopment
that's Golden Gate Avenue is that right
yeah so these are I've shown this clip
before but many of you have not seen it
these are members of the Black Panther
Party and an out outtake from a film
made by California newsreel and they're
posting in the area of Divisadero you'll
see a few landmarks and a vet this is
pretty early this is I'm gonna say 67
and 68 Huey
the work of the artwork of Emory Douglas
the poster newspaper and multimedia
artist of the Black Panther Party see if
you can pick out the FBI infiltrator
liner liquor Lobby
so a family from Michigan the man was a
delegate to the Denver to the Republican
National Convention and these are the
home movies he shot in San Francisco and
on the convention floor
back then they were radicals haven't
done the research Harvey yeah
there's almost Spreckels up there city
of Paris they're gonna go to the White
House - it was a different era
anybody remember who was running
Eisenhower did you vote for Stevenson
yeah yeah I sold my bald guys rule
the Republican Party you know was
remembered as the party of Abe Lincoln
and the Democratic Party was the party
of southern segregationist so they were
still quite a number of
african-americans who loyally voted
Republican and a few of them were at the
convention there's an odd walkie-talkie
from a newsman mid-century modern some
of these are recognizable faces but not
in my consciousness unfortunately we'll
see one person I could recognize I'm
just I'm not good on my Republicans yeah
you seen one fat bald guy white bald guy
you've seen it all yeah it looks nice
Senator Everett Dirksen there in the
background who had a spoken-word
recording career and there's Nixon
accepting the vice presidential
nomination and Eisenhower with an arm in
the front down in front
Seppo courtesy once again of Jack
Tillman II this was a film the context
was the preparedness Day Parade in San
Francisco and 1916 there was a bombing
and Tom Mooney was arrested and framed
for that bombing and served quite a long
time in prison moody and Billings yes
thank you I think I like the giant woman
dropping money better
[Applause]
the Wobblies
[Applause]
and now for our finale we turn it up a
tiny bit the volume made in 1955 by a
skilled amateur - leo Pellegrini
feel stadium
this film was rediscovered thanks to
dawn van Covell
people were so scared to get on that
thing it moved like five miles an hour
cost a quarter or something but they
always thought it was going to collapse
there's the surf club the big dipper
went down in 5555 sometimes it may be
earlier
[Music]
[Music]
there's the Shula or however you say it
it's an old gorya Dineen artist slope
Boulevard
Labor Day week in 1972 as the last day
of Playland
Castro theater yep
Castro theater and the lower right
[Music]
hold your breath
[Music]
professional driver closed course
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you